we used to go like camping every year in
france for like three weeks dude i was
okay
you're gonna think wow connor you're a
violent like [ __ ] 11 year old okay
i i [ __ ] spent all my time in the
arcades i remember this one time
this kid had been like taunting me yeah
his french kid i [ __ ] hated him
you've been taunting me for like days
and i'm playing metal slug right and you
know how you put like two credits in
like you press the credit button yeah
it's like oh cause i'm playing and i put
another one in for me
when i die this [ __ ] this 11 year old
[ __ ]
who comes along presses the start credit
button and then walks away
and then i immediately just turn around
just [ __ ] smack him with the face
oh my god i got in so much trouble i had
like an angry french dad
shouting at me at like i'm like 11 right
and i'm like
this is his dad [ __ ] shouting at me
because this kid's crying yeah i'm like
i'm gonna finish my
and game i'll deal with this and my dad
had such a [ __ ] go at me
you were that xbox kid when yeah i was
definitely like
a pen top right i was like i was such an
angry kid i have no idea why
but i'm glad though because like now i
just like just can't even get angry
to be fair i'd be pretty pissed off too
if somebody random [ __ ] kid came up
to me did that yeah when you're like 11
right this is also
my parents didn't give me much money
yeah and i would only i would always use
it on the games right so to me
this kid had just taken like the only
money i was getting yeah like
that whole trip and i was like oh no oh
we all know like two an eleven year old
like
three like like three like two or like
three credits or
slug is like the equivalent to your
mom's credit card yeah i [ __ ] love
medals like man that kid took my credit
no like i can totally understand why you
got angry i just thought man there's
this is the problem there's a few steps
between
between taking someone's credit and
smacking someone in this package
this kid had been giving me [ __ ] he's
like a campsite he'd been giving me [ __ ]
for days
i'm just like i'm done dude i'm done i'm
fuming
i just straight up punched it i got so
much [ __ ] for that and then like two
days later the same kid
who i punched had a black eye he came he
came while i was on my other [ __ ]
game
just pulls out the plug and i [ __ ]
chased him but he ran off
did you oh i was i was giving him him i
was gonna [ __ ]
kill him [ __ ]
pulled out the plug whilst i was mid
metal slug i'm sorry wow